buenas tardes es un paquete de 38 leyes
las que empezaron a ser debatidas de
esta misma tarde como ustedes ven a mis
espaldas en el parlamento británico en
la cámara de los comunes estas leyes van
desde tratar de aliviar la economía
británica altamente golpeada por la
pandemia del coi 19 también dar apoyo a
la población que está sufriendo por el
aumento de la crisis en el costo de vida
y también dar más seguridad a las
ciudades británicas hay seis leyes
específicas sobre el break sheet tratar
de adaptar las leyes británicas que
todavía están en línea con las de la
unión europea tras el divorcio también
proteger el acuerdo de paz de irlanda
del norte de 1998 y medidas para frenar
el cruce ilegal de inmigrantes a través
del canal de la mancha como lo mencionas
la atención estuvo centrada en la
ausencia de la reina isabel según el
palacio de buckingham la reina tras
escuchar consejos de sus médicos no
asistió porque tiene problemas de
movilidad estuvo como lo mencionan
leyendo el discurso de la reina tiene la
jefe de estado de este país su hijo el
príncipe carlos el primero en la línea
sucesión por supuesto la salud de la
reina isabel siempre ha sido un asunto
de primer interés en este país el
príncipe carlos dijo en este discurso
que la reina está muy deseosa de poder
celebrar las fiestas de su jubileo de
platino con el que se marcarán los 70
años en el trono la reina como lo
mencionas no ha dejado de leer el
discurso en el parlamento como con el
que inicia el año legislativo en este
país desde 1959 esto porque estaba en el
último en la última etapa del embarazo
de su cuarto hijo eduardo